as Russia and China and now India really
opened up to to global capitalism to to
foreign firms the the very first
reaction of consumers was a great hunger
for Western brands local products if
there are made at all where poor quality
dangerous and absolutely lacking in
aspirational value whatsoever so these
new markets the so-called BRICS have
proved you know incredibly incredibly
attractive a beauty companies and
they've grown incredibly quickly China
in nineteen eighty didn't have a beauty
industry Mao Zedong had abolished it as
a matter of fact is regarded it as a
sign of bourgeois bourgeois decadence
it's now the fourth biggest beauty
market in the world because it as the
SEC is the third-biggest Russia is the
eighth biggest so all of these markets
have seen this in pouring of Western
brands the interesting the interesting
thing is that over time we've seen
particularly in the case of China
growing confidence among consumers in
traditional beauty ideals and practices
and this has increasingly are obliged
companies to consider and implement what
we can call local customization of
various kinds so in China today there's
a there's a huge demand for local
ingredients you know ginseng skin cream
or or or whatever and so even if a brand
is ur is a global brand like Olay or
l'oreal paris actually the ingredients
often reflector a sort of local content
but it's more than more than that
companies
shifted again from in China in
particular from using Western models
which a brand like lawyer Paris always
did to using local models but it's more
than this because they increasingly or
now pretty much always use local
photographers local agencies to do all
the all the shots because they are very
very anxious to capture capture local
feelings so we live in a I think you're
in an interesting period where
globalization and tribal ization are a
sort of dramatically interacting in the
global industry and I think nobody is
quite sure about the exact balance and
consumers are kind of saying different
things they're saying yeah we want these
fabulous in Paris and New York brands
because they are aspirational but
they're also saying we want them to be
locally relevant
if we go back again to the the early
19th century no one place was associated
with being especially beautiful if we
look at the the perfume industry which
someone would regard is at the center of
the industry Britain was a bigger
producer of fragrance in perfume for
much of the first half of the 19th
century bigger than bigger than France
but by the middle of the 19th century in
Paris you have the development of haute
couture of fashion of Paris as a kind of
a spectacle with the rebuilding of the
city with wide boulevards and the growth
of the perfume industry becomes cloak
closely associated with this cluster of
fashionable luxurious industries so by
the end of the 19th century Paris is
regarded as the benchmark of all that's
chic and fashionable through outdoor
throughout the world throughout the
world and fragrances and beauty industry
is is part of that and this process is
self really reinforcing certainly they
be the benchmark of aspiration is self
reinforcing but because Paris is so
aspirational so talented entrepreneurs
artists and other people the suppliers
of the beauty industry all cluster
around Paris as well so you both have a
you know what economists would call it
agglomeration effects and reputation
effects and that proved incredibly
strong and persistent throughout the
next century Paris a symbol of of chic
pneus
and style and aspiration and femininity
New York is a slightly different story
it sir by the early 20th century United
States is the world's biggest economies
what richest economy New York is the
major commercial center entrepreneurs
and others are attracted to New York
it's a giant port through which
ingredients of the industry come in and
so it starts to develop a again a
cluster of our entrepreneurs but then
yeah the growth of of Hollywood of the
American film industry in which New York
is quite closely tied as the center of
finance in the center of a lot of talent
I think is is really important in taking
the vision of America around the world
and then in the interwar years and
afterwards a group of entrepreneurs like
Elizabeth Arden Helena Rubinstein later
estee lauder Charles medicine develop
expensive luxury brands of of cosmetics
skincare and fragrances which provide
also New York in the united states with
range of not only mass brands but also
prestigious brands and so the new york
the united states comes to represent a a
different vision of beauty division
that's more accessible more democratic
view of beauty are less complex less
chic more hip more exciting just like
New York itself and it's an interesting
question why these two cities have
continued that role it's partly because
there's so much talent clustered if
you're a rich certain role a certain
size but it's also it's also about the
cities themselves both
cities have emotional associations in
people's heads Paris of you cafes and
the left bank New York of skyscrapers
and and energy and those images the
cities today are you could say the
cities today us are still are still
having those features so there's no
disconnect between people's imaginations
of those cities and those cities today
even though they are two of the most
fast changing cosmopolitan evolving
cities you could want want in the world
so I think the brand image of those
cities which is very important in the
beauty industry is is persistent and
realistic you can get on a plane go to
those cities and you actually see what
you imagined it to be now it's a very
interesting question if other cities can
catch up and I thought about that quite
a lot for example Milan after the Second
World War develops as a major global
fashion center but it doesn't develop as
a beauty capital London has always been
on the fringes of the beauty industry
and at various times has become hip and
exciting 1960s you know swinging London
because Twiggy all the rest of it but
never quite never quite sort of made it
as as a beauty capital now one can think
of Tokyo Shanghai or Rio as has
potentials